hundreds have never before seen
documents providing new insight into the
one October shooter thank you for
joining us at six I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Brian Loftus the nation's deadliest
mass shooting taking the lives of 60
people and why the shooter did it a
mystery a news now investigator David
Charles going through those documents
from the FBI and David what did they say
well these 600 or so pages of documents
we went through are essentially FBI
agent interviews they look like this you
see it says FBI there on the top
unclassified but these documents don't
do our spell out why this mass murder
occurred and that is a question so many
of us want answered
the heavily redacted documents paint a
glimpse of the man responsible for
killing 60 people and injuring hundreds
more at the Route 91 Harvest Country
Music Festival on October 1st 2017.
Paddock was very strange a person
believed to be a neighbor telling the
FBI he never made eye contact and he did
not want to shake his neighbor's hand
when she first met him they never had
any friendly chats the person saying
Paddock never had the lights on in his
house and he always wore gloves another
person telling the FBI Paddock was a
prolific video player visiting Las Vegas
once every three months losing 38
thousand dollars in mid-september that
year one interviewee saying Paddock was
an upset High Roller banned from some
casinos for quote playing well and
winning large quantities of money that
person saying quote Paddock was very
upset at the way casinos were treating
him in other high rollers the stress
could easily be what caused Paddock to
snap another person telling the FBI
Paddock was quote fascinated with the
1995 Oklahoma City Bombing and that
quote he thought Hitler was a good man
the documents do not lay out an exact
motive something Metro Police also could
not determine in their investigation
Governor Joe Lombardo then Clark County
Sheriff this report is not going to
answer every question or even answer the
biggest question as to why he did what
he did the documents are filled with
witness interviews many from people
calling the FBI in the days after one
October with tips one woman saying
Paddock photobombed her while she was
taking a selfie at a strip Taco Bell
several hours before the shooting
another person telling the FBI she was
staying at the Mandalay Bay for the
concert went to the festival grounds but
quote things didn't feel right and she
left
certainly Eerie to hear stories like
that the governor did not have a comment
on the release of these documents today
we're live near the strip in Tropicana
I'm David Charles 8 News Now
Metro sending us a statement about the
document release it says the department
and the FBI were unable to determine a
motive for the shooter it goes on to say
quote speculating on a motive causes
more harm to the hundreds of people who
were victims that night we do not
believe these documents will shed new
light in the case